mindestens 174 erntehelfer haben sich in
mamming auf einem landwirtschaftlichen
betrieb mit dem corona virus infiziert
der gesamte betrieb steht unter
quarantäne und wird von einer
sicherheitsfirma bewacht live aus dem
ort in mamming ist merz luisa volkhausen
zugeschaltet guten morgen luisa droht
dem ort denn jetzt einloggen
nach aktuellem stand soll ist kein login
für den gesamten kreis geben
man sieht hinter mir das komplett
abgeriegelt alle 480 mitarbeiter stehen
und strenger quarantäne
aber man kann die krone infektion als
relativ klar lokalisieren auf diesen
betrieb deswegen lockt dann für die
gesamte region ist nach aktuellem stand
nicht geplant aber um 10 uhr wird
ministerpräsident markus söder noch eine
pressekonferenz geben und dann erfahren
wir auch mehr welche maßnahmen werden
denn aktuell ergriffen damit sich die
krone infizierten eben nicht weiter
vermehren
also nach aktuellem stand können sich
alle besorgten bürger hier im ort die
gerade kostenlos testen lassen gerade
jetzt ihren bayern haben ja auch die
ferien begonnen
viele haben vielleicht reisen geplant
also kostenlose tests für die alle
bewohner hier im landkreis
außerdem hat gesundheitsministerin
melanie huml gestern angekündigt die
massen festsieger zum wechsel
schlachtbetriebe im gespräch waren jetzt
auch auf ernste betriebe auszuweiten